I want people to understand that we're
really normal people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have Ambitions we have dreams and
back home some of us were engineers
doctors artists athletes and we didn't
really choose to to leave our our
countries we were abandoned to leave our
homes friends you know everything
we have because we wanted to to be safe
[Music]
I went to the swimming pool and on
weekends I was either by my grandma or
my with my friends I had a very simple
beautiful life
I had like lived for almost five years
in the war electricity Cottage water
Cottage there there was bombing
happening every day we understood okay
it's not a choice anymore to stay here
because we weren't safe
foreign
[Music]
which was a very small one and we were
18 people on it with one child and then
the water starts get it starts getting
in and then my sister jumped to the
water and me from the other side and
then to other guys we tried to stabilize
the boat we tried to stir it back
because it was it was windy and it was
all it was being pushed back it took us
three hours and a half to get to to
Greece then
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I've been dreaming of that since I was
nine years old and I wanted to be this
really successful swimmer I'm kind of
glad about how it turned out and that I
did represent the refugee Olympic team
it made me understand that I do have a
voice and I can't change something to
the better
you should do it there's so much more
than an Olympian
ready
[Music]
[Music]
it showed me how much I can change in
the world and I think that is way more
important than any gold medal
[Music]